and welcome back to the Daily everybody
a four-year-old girl Oklahoma girl
hasn't been seen since earlier this week
and now police have arrested the couple
that was supposed to be caring for her
Athena Brownfield lives in Searle
Southwest of Oklahoma City her
five-year-old sister was spotted by a
postal worker wandering alone police
arrested Alicia Adams who was supposed
to be caring for the girls charging her
with child neglect her husband Ivan
Adams was found in Arizona and is being
extradited back to Oklahoma but still no
sign of Athena details on her family and
why she had caregiver caregivers is not
immediately clear her sister is now with
child services trash services are halted
in the city while authorities search for
Athena police are also canvassing
neighborhoods asking for anyone with
security video to come forward
so Brian what exactly is neglect in
Oklahoma it's pretty broad as a
definition Jesse it's not providing or
denying child with proper hygiene and
education or Health Care can even be not
providing or denying a Child clothing
food or housing allowing a child to be
exposed to age inappropriate situations
or even criminal activity it could even
be abandoning a child or leaving them
under the supervision of an
inappropriate person which could be the
situation here or another minor so when
you're talking about child neglect it is
Broad and for many reasons probably
should be because there are so many
things that a child needs from a
guardian and a parent and if to take it
away from them or to deny them and that
can be criminal I agree with you you
know you're in the care and custody of
someone who and this is a person who
can't care for themselves so obviously
that definition definition should be
broad Nema I want to go to you are there
extra resources that are available to
help search for Athena because I wonder
why is they're not been an Amber Alert
yeah there are extra resources Federal
resources we know local law enforcement
they're searching for Athena on land CNA
you got helicopters you got boats
obviously you got vehicles on the ground
I think the issue in this case with
respect to Amber Alert and there's a lot
of criticism of Oklahoma police for not
issuing the Amber Alert is their
specific criteria and that criteria is
that they believe that the child has
been abducted I don't think they think
that's happened because Athena's sister
was wandering the streets discovered by
postal worker so you know I hope for the
best I hope she has found but I'm very
concerned that if they don't think the
child's been abducted if she just
wandered off I hope they find her and
they find her healthy and a lot because
the other way of looking at it is they
might be thinking the worst at this
point in an amber alert is not necessary
a community in Massachusetts gathered
for a prayer vigil Thursday night to
support the family of missing Cohasset
Mother Anna Walsh
[Music]
[Music]
more than 100 people attended the
15-minute vigil where prayers hymns and
moments of Silence were held for 30 the
39 year old who's been missing since
January 4th her husband 47 year old
Brian Walsh has been arrested and
accused of misleading the police
investigation you see prosecutors said
there's strong circumstantial evidence
tying him to the case including a bloody
knife cleaning supplies that were
purchased a newly cleaned car an
internet search history the suspect is
also awaiting sentencing on an unrelated
federal case involving an online scheme
selling fake Indie Warhol paintings he's
pleaded not guilty in his wife's case
and is currently being held on five
hundred thousand dollars Bond
when we come back actor Kevin Spacey is
back in the hot seat as more sexual
assault charges are brought against him
in the UK will he secure another Victory
or face serious trouble across the pond
[Music]
and welcome back everybody we finish out
Today's Show by shining a light on actor
Kevin Spacey you remember him well he is
making headlines yet again for alleged
sexual assaults the Oscar winner
appeared virtually in a London courtroom
on Friday pleading not guilty to seven
more sexual assault charges a male
accuser claims Spacey sexually assaulted
him on several occasions between 2001
and 2004. judge Mark wall agreed to
combine this indictment with an earlier
one involving five similar charges
connected to three additional men in the
UK Spacey pleaded not guilty to those
charges last summer this follows
Spacey's victory in New York just last
fall when actor Anthony Anthony Rapp
accused him of sexual assault in the
1980s a pre-trial review is set for
April to decide if all 12 UK charges
will be pursued at this trial in June in
the meantime Kevin Spacey remains out on
bail Nema I'll start with you are there
any standout differences in this type of
case in the UK versus the one in the
United States
oh big differences first you're talking
about a criminal case versus civil and
the fact that Spacey's lawyers were able
to win here in New York with a much
lower burden of proof for the alleged
victim the plaintiff it's going to
embolden them there in the UK of course
on the other hand whenever you have more
victims alleged them that bodes well for
the prosecution can overwhelm the
defense because even though they don't
believe one it's hard for a judge or a
jurors to disbelieve more than one
victim so it's gonna be interesting to
see if Kevin Spacey's lawyers try to
sever those trials they still have up
until March to decide whether to do so
and adopt more of a divide and conquer
strategy or to attack all of them at
once not to make a light of it but I
think they could have done it better
with the courtroom sketch that didn't
really look like Kevin Spacey I think it
could have been done better that's a
side note Brian want to go to you why
would the judge join Spacey's two cases
together and what does that mean for the
trials when we look at it overall right
so uh like Nemo was saying they might
want to several the cases but the
opposite of sever is to join them the
easy answer is is called judicial
economy and lack of bias judicial
economy just means hey we're going to
have these two different trials with
such similar uh allegations and they
have one case we have three alleged
victims and one having one you might as
well just make one big case with four
and so long as adding that additional uh
alleged victim to the other three
doesn't bias the case overall that makes
sense to combine the cases now it's up
for the defense as Nema hinted at to say
hey we shouldn't keep these cases
together someone's not going to convict
Spacey because of one individual piece
of evidence but because of the totality
of all the witnesses they're going to
say hey well he must be guilty just
because of the sheer number of alleged
victims so we'll see how that continues
and what they decide well in terms of
legal outcomes Kevin Spacey's been doing
very well you know everything that he's
been hit with seems to fight it back
Brian Nema thanks so much appreciate it
as always everyone out there thanks so
much for joining us here on Long crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
foreign